Wanda I know we can't stay like this
before I go no
I feel like myself
Gotta Die
stop it empty don't do this right now
he's lives in me oh
he's like cool
you are awesome
wires and blood and oh every time I
re-watch this
you are my sadness
help
oh
you're my everything honestly you're my
love oh
also the most expensive vibrator in the
world empty stuff
why do you gotta ruin it this is a good
moment that ruins
you raped Wanda Mission Number One how
can you do this yeah
I just play too many games oh
ah
I have been a voice with nobody
my body but not human enough this is a
moment
this is the moment where I was like okay
uh Vision does have a soul I've been a
real jerk toward Vision until now and
now I know
yeah what will you be next
what will you be next whose
Consciousness will you be in who will
you be inside of vision and can it be me
It's Gonna be Me will it be me get that
turtleneck in me all the way in Hmm
this is how we're starting today with
vision balls deep in me
[Laughter]
[Music]
welcome back to New rockstars the
Scarlet Witch May return to reunite with
vision and Vision Quest work entitled a
new series confirmed to be in
development in Marvel Studios alongside
Wonder Man breaking news as of this
state being Yaya Abdul medin II coming
in as Simon Williams a character who has
connections with this whole white Vision
era in the West Coast Avengers of the
comics but isn't Wanda dead in the MCU
it isn't one division uh arguably
different soul than the what is Greek
Vision we knew in one division maybe
maybe not not exactly the one division
Scarlet Vision that we knew he is a
different guy though some of the same
ships of Theseus uh planks that are
shared there I guess it is even fair to
call coding a soul well this synthazoid
hopes so because otherwise there's
nothing ticking in here it's been almost
two years but let's dust off the OG
inside Marvel sign in and ask ourselves
nailed it having said that in a minute
I gave it up for lamp
inside Marvel let's do Rockstar's weekly
Marvel reaction show talking about all
the biggest news in Marvel I'm Eric Voss
with me today it's Jessica Clemons and
Mt welcome back my friends hey you love
to go back all right dressed as white
vision
oh my goodness and you look amazing it's
one it's it's Halloween today when we
are recording this show uh but it I
guess it's November 2nd or 3rd when
you're watching it and Jess is just uh
All Saints Day celebration of white
Vision the soul that he does have I
don't have a soul we both don't I don't
have this one Let's uh for the record I
do not have a soul just kidding not
since I sacrificed mine to Mephisto I
don't have a soul but I I hope to regain
it I want it open with that clip from
that one division finale not just
because it's one of my favorite all-time
MCU moments or because we really need a
good morning cry but because I think
it's just the best possible example of
what we have to look forward to in this
Vision Quest show you know I don't think
any relationship it phase four was
nearly as powerful or as inspiring or as
hopeful as the one between Wanda and
vision I think we all need more of it we
need to see at least one side of this
relationship try to find the other so I
think we need to talk about why phase
five needs Vision Quest and and a little
later in the show we're going to dig
deeper into this Simon Williams guy
Abdul Mateen the second news because I
think he's gonna be amazing in the MCU
and I really really hope that they do
tie it in at least a little bit with
white Vision because I think there there
is a way to bring those together not
that they need to but is Yaya Watchman
is this is this the oh yes Dr Manhattan
this is Dr Manhattan yeah yeah this is
uh yeah yeah
MCU has too many beautiful black men
making me jealous I don't like it too
many handsome black men
[Laughter]
is so beautiful and he's honestly his
track record as a hero in superhero
movies he's to me is the one that's been
non-affected and when I say not affected
like we always are like oh yeah remember
when Chris Evans did the Human Torch
like I don't think too many people have
like been like bringing up his other
roles as much so I'm really happy to see
him get into this and it'll be a
different role for him to take on Yo him
as black Banta was probably my one of my
favorite parts of Aquaman like he was a
fantastic Black Manta he's he's just
gonna take a little piece of every
franchise and he can yes easily because
he did great as in Watchmen he oh my God
and Watchmen
phenomenon Watchman and you know uh you
gotta imagine we're gonna have a scene
at some point in the next two years
where yahi abdulmentin is talking to
Jonathan majors and those two Ivy League
trade actors who who got some heat for
calling this clown work it's not clown
where clown works hard my friends clown
work requires a lot of discipline I been
doing it my whole life and you know all
the internet is like it's not clown work
I like it's a compliment to call
something clown work in my opinion and
it's because these two actors know what
they're doing they know what they're
doing and they're gonna blow our
freaking Minds we might get into it but
won't his character in Watchmen as Dr
Manhattan kind of align with white
Vision very well yes yes it does it'll
be the same kind of person and I will
love this I will reap I will sew this
I'll get into it okay go on let's start
by breaking down this deadline report
from last week about this vision quest
uh so it reports that a second one
division spin-off series focusing on
Paul bettany's vision is in the works of
Marvel Studios for Disney plus sources
tell deadline titled Vision Quest the
potential series which is opening a
writer's room next week will be about
the vision Bettany trying to regain his
memory and Humanity I hear and I hear
it's just this kind of thing that you
see a deadline articles written by uh
what's her name like she's always just
like I hear from my sources they
whispered into my ear I'm Rita Skeeter
and little bugs like to tell me the
little inside dealings at the studio
Lots little rumors my little birds fly
into my window and they whisper
to I hear them I hear them I just think
it's such a weird editorial choice if
they do a deadline and it doesn't make
sense to me I'm sorry to act that out
I'm in a weird getting mood
it's Halloween the article goes on to
say well the focus is on Vision word is
there a possibility for one to maximum
of Elizabeth Olsen to appear which would
make sense given how interconnected the
two characters stories are in the MCU
yeah uh says someone who clearly just
watched the MCU once in their lives but
anyway like the other one division
spin-off the green lighted series Act of
the House of Harkness headlined by
Catherine Hahn Vision Quest is overseen
by one division Creator writer and
executive producer Jack Shafer I hear
some purple Studios and Pat natively
common the new spin-off has been
unofficially referred to by some as the
white Vision project after the most
recent on-screen version of the
character now a quick reminder of that
character where we left Vision or
Scarlet vision and white Vision in the
one division finale Vision engage white
vision and the ship of these debate so
you know when a ship is rebuilt he's in
the same links as before which is a true
ship of Theseus white Vision
acknowledged the Paradox but Vision
tells him quote
perhaps the rot is the memories the wear
and tear Are the Voyages the wood
touched by Theseus himself and I just
want to ask you guys you ever feel like
your memories are just rot
down more than ever Eric now more than
ever now that I've uh I can't remember
anything
um literally anything
um I forgot how my own name is spelled
it's only two letters it's pretty it's
two letters both of you should we unbox
this should we stop what we're doing
right now and talk about this just ask
the question that needs to show up in
the Chiron just what's going on what is
going on that's a valid question
happening dude are you okay I'm fine
white Vision responds I have not
retained memories but Scarlet Vision
says but you do have the data it is
merely being kept from you and the white
Vision says a weapon to be more easily
controlled but certainly you're the true
Vision because you believe yourself to
be and Scarlet Vision says well that was
once the case but upon meeting you I've
been disabused of that notion as a
carbon-based synthazoid your memory
storage is not so easily wiped may I
Vision gives a little tap to that gem on
white vision's head and Montage shows
that white vision's memories are being
restored he has all the information that
was there right up until the moment of
his death and he goes I Envision and
then he flies off again he blasts off
through the Skylight uh that's the last
we see him Scarlet Vision was left
behind in West View and Faded when Wanda
dropped the hex white Vision though is
still at large he's fully possessing his
memories up through the moment of his
death in wakanda but probably not any of
the sitcom events that happened in
Westview prior to sword activating him
however we should note that since what
is uh grief if not love persevering
happened around the time of Civil War
white Vision uh is the same vision who
has that memory of telling Wanda that so
a lot of them the core aspects of a
vision that we know of that we love
about him white Vision has uh recently
Kevin feige hinted a variety that Wanda
maximoff might have survived Multiverse
madness he said I don't know that we saw
her under Rubble we saw a tower coming
down a little red flash I don't know
what that means and I'm just taking a
note from the variety interview they
said like kind of an up upward tone is
the way he's an up tone so I was just
you know taking the acting of them I'm
not making fun of the way he talks
you made him sound like Jerry Seinfeld
it's like hey what's going on
should I die she's just an arrival
I'm sorry so it sounds to me like Vision
Quest is gonna be a season two of One
Division more specifically it kind of
reboot a season one instead of Wanda
creating a synthetic reality to recreate
Vision I think we're gonna see Vision on
a quest to digitally manifest his love
in an inner reality where he can be with
Wanda again I'm picturing this Wally
scenario this robot who's just forever
Locked In Forever devoted to Eve to his
Eve you know white vision is going to
circle the globe Without End searching
for Wanda he's gonna dig up the rubble
find her not there uh I think Wanda's
gonna stay dead for now and 616 maybe
she'll return in secret Wars I think
everyone's gonna return on that show but
um white Vision with no ability to
travel the Multiverse it's gonna try to
rebuild her in his mind Palace to uh you
know he's gonna give her the voice of a
digital Consciousness that's made up of
his Memories the right of her that only
he can see you know like in Truman's
show how Truman's like tearing up
magazines to like assemble the face of
the woman who was taken from him that
kind of little tragic moment I think
that's what white Vision that's going to
be the quest he's on uh I think the
Consciousness that he sees of Wanda is
going to appear to him kind of like an
imaginary girlfriend who tells him to
let go of his quest and move on uh and
focus on his present needs the present
needs maybe being a father figure to
Billy and Tommy maybe uh we'll project
forward into a possible future wife is
just sitting on the the rubble of Earth
thousands of years in the future still
still waiting for his love to come home
in the plot of turf that he bought for
her in Western New Jersey but only only
the the outline of that house is left as
the rest of the world's uh completely
eroded around him he's waiting for Wanda
forever but he's going to wake up from
that from that future to the present
crisis to help Billy and in some
Avengers level threat set up the Young
Avengers that's what I hope this is but
I want to hear from YouTube what do you
think uh what do you want to see from
Vision in Vision Quest I liken this
storyline in the comics where he
basically got his he was like
constructed by Wonder Man or had the
same whatever brain as Wonder Man and
but I like that that storyline is maybe
being switched for Wanda by proxy gave
White Vision his new brain because he
got his like I am vision from our Wanda
Vision Vision so it's like by proxy you
just got it directly and now maybe you
have the brain waves of Wanda so I like
the idea that him showing up is him
showing up to like correct Wanda for
what she did I know in the comics there
was like a part where Vision before he
turned into like white Vision where he
kind of went crazy and like tried to
destroy the planet so maybe Wanda after
what happened Multiverse madness he
hears about and he's like I need to
correct this wrong figure uh but he also
still has the like I love her still I so
I kind of want that to be kind of
settled out I know Wonder man's coming
it seems like we need to kind of put him
in there but I also just want this to be
I need a conclusion I don't think we
still got the conclusion after one
Division I think now with white Vision
having a little bit of Wanda we now have
opened another door so I need a
conclusion to that that makes sense I
agree and I get that I like both of your
ideas especially like you know this idea
of vision sort of like reconstructing
um like a digital Palace in his mind of
like doing like a reverse like digital
One Division I think that would be
really fun
um but like I honestly think that Vision
quests is going to be or or rather
should be
um just like Vision finding himself like
because like up until this point in the
MCU this is like he's been basically
under somebody's watch or some under
like he hasn't been his own person
um he was working with the Avengers and
like he was sort of like they were
keeping tabs on him because like the
whole Age of Ultron thing happened
understandably he was like created by
Ultron so like they're like ah this is
like a super weapon that we have to keep
tabs on at all times but now that he's
like out of like M.I.A out of Swords um
watch and like out of the Avengers watch
this is the first time Vision has been
free and his own person and I think that
Vision Quest could be just Vision just
like all right who am I like he had that
whole freak out with um seeing himself
in the library it's like all right I
still don't really I know that I
envisioned but like what does that mean
and I think that Vision Quest is
probably like all right here's me trying
to find who I am in this world and like
you know what is my personality what
what do I actually want and um like
maybe like this new version of vision
doesn't like Wanda like this is a this
could be a completely new
um being and he's just like you know
what like the old vision would have
liked you but like me now with these new
experiences in this new like uh maybe
like with his sword programming sort of
like giving him this predisposition to
like wanna like kill Wanda or like want
to like not like Wanda
um he's just like you know what I'm just
doing my own thing which is why I didn't
show up Multiverse Madness who cares I'm
a deadbeat dad
um so yeah I don't know that's just mine
did you read Tom King's uh Vision story
where he's a robot and he has a robotic
family oh yeah oh yeah that was yeah
television
do you want it like that where he's like
trying so hard to be human
I've wanted them to adapt that run
specifically because I love vivision a
lot his daughter in that run like that
gets introduced in that run she's in the
she's in the Champions and like she's a
she's a prominent figure in Marvel Now
um but yeah no no I think that'd be
great I would love that so much that
would be insane if Vision Quest turned
into that like he creates a different
robot family
is just like we were supposed to be a
family one day that's I think this is a
great idea like um the when we went into
one division we thought wanna Vision was
gonna be more that Tom King run and they
only just brought in little elements
like Sparky the dog and things like that
but what if we truly got the Tom King
version of that and he's making
synthazoid versions of Wanda and Billy
and Tommy instead that's how we get like
and the rest of them and it's like kind
of freaky and dark a little bit but it's
almost like a replay but it's
specifically that title and that's how
we get in the whole Smith Zoid family
gets introduced I when I do this it
means like all together I agree not me
telling you to shut up it looks like I'm
telling you to be quiet but I'm like no
as a whole together I love the idea of
how dark that could be and come off of
him being like no I'm actively trying to
be good like I made a family of robots
and we live in this suburb house and
we're being weird and everyone's like
you you're a runaway robot that belongs
to the government you shouldn't be here
like I that storyline could go so well
but I don't know if they're gonna try
doing like because one division did such
a good job of being creepy and really
dark and being like a family-friendly
program that that would kind of mimic
what we'd want a Vision Quest so I think
Vision Quest might go a different route
but I I would love that I would eat that
up in a heartbeat and also making I
guess Eight Episodes of that seems a
little harder than and a lot of plot
holes of like what what is he what's
going on like there's so much to White
Vision especially from the comic books
it's like which I don't think they can't
even address because they kind of did it
all in one division
to address white vision from the comic
books like his storyline except for
when he got captured or something sorry
I'm now going off I'm like how could the
comics correlate with his vision quiz
what if here's a pitch like what if uh
in the rubble of Avengers I just like
the idea of white Vision sifting through
Rubble I would like a full episode of
that please you know just see what he
finds
um like you know kind of a you know a
Storage Wars kind of deal but uh what if
he finds in the rebel of Avengers
compound uh Wanda's old movie box of
DVDs that she watched Malcolm the middle
and we can get a continuation of what we
saw in uh in one division in that first
season and like Vision each episode kind
of has like a different sitcom all the
other things that weren't addressed in
one division we see Vision trying to
recreate it in his own way because he
can like create his own weird little
reality I mean he made a cape appear
from him like can't he just like project
things into existence in his own that
are connected to him in a weird way uh I
feel like we could see him do that and
all the other sitcoms we didn't get to
like sister sister or That's So Raven I
want to see those
what what happened with that so ribbon
Vision that's so Vision yes
it's so mysteriously
he's like I don't have a wife or kid
is it a yep that's me I ain't got a wife
or kids
um so do you think going off that there
was a piece in the comic where he was he
felt bad that he emotionally just wasn't
there for Wanda and was like I don't he
literally was like them kids because I
don't these kids aren't mine they're not
my kids they're the other Visions kids
so do you think uh this Vision Quest
could be him in search of finding like
the emotion because I don't think he got
fully when he touched Vision I don't
think he fully got everything he's a big
complex cyborg so it's probably like I'm
missing a giant portion of what could
make me relate to people and I'm always
gonna look for that so do you think it
could be him just searching for what
makes him whole and maybe uh maybe the
government is like we need to bring this
thing back this is ours we created it
yeah no I think that that's that's a
good point considering that like this
vision is like a new person like you
could have somebody's memories like
memories are just data but like it's you
yourself experiencing those memories is
what makes you
um a person like what gives you your
personality and that's really that's a
really good point like he doesn't have a
personality yet because he was just this
robot it was just like a Terminator like
heal this person all right now he has
the visuals memories of like the Scarlet
Witch and like it is uh being uh sort of
like a fake robot human person
um and he's just like all right what
does that mean for me like how do I move
forward like what how do I who am I and
I think that like we're gonna see a
different side to Vision that we hadn't
seen in the original Vision we're
probably going to see a more
um like more probably a more angrier
side I was gonna say I think we're gonna
get a bad one I think we're gonna get a
bad Vision yeah because like there is
the whole factor of like he was rebooted
with chaos magic like the sword used the
chaos magic in that
um playing thing to turn them on so like
having a chaos magic source as we've
seen with Wanda and with the whole
Multiverse of Madness dark hole thing
that probably invites you to some some
dark darker influence yeah so um I'm
very interested to see how like his
personality evolves in this series and
that's a good point because when you are
flooded with memories the way he has
um they're not organized like uh it's
not just like the the flashes of visuals
uh that makes a memory a memory has a
physiological component there's like a
muscle memory that goes there's a
feeling there's like a physical
sensation in your gut or like shame or
Pride or Joy or something like that that
makes your heart beat and it's very
specific Cadence each memory is a little
bit different and white Vision doesn't
have that I think he needs to be taught
how to sort and categorize all of his
memories and that's the the vision
that's a quest ahead of him uh is like
he needs someone to help him figure out
what order all these what order and
priority these memories need to be
sorted into and that someone should be
the kid from Iron Man 3. just kidding
can you imagine could you imagine if
Riri Williams found white vision and
she's just like holy [ __ ] I can't what
what are you get out of Chicago
what are you doing here
honestly like I feel like white Vision
should show up like in um Iron Art in
subcapacity or armor Wars that would be
sick if he just rips through the
Machinery or something yeah like he has
a piece of Stark Tech so like you know
that's that's the relation there so
we're gonna keep talking about this with
Simon Williams
um but first let's thank some friends
who help just make this episode Helix
sleep sleep is important and here at new
rockstars We Trust Helix to protect our
sleep with the best mattresses in the
world I have a helix mattress as does MT
recently producer Zach and producers
John also got Helix mattresses Helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and your sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you everybody's
unique and Helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses mattress is great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains and
even Helix plus matches or plus size
sleepers producer John took the Helix
quiz and he was matched with the Helix
dusk mattress because he's a back
sleeper and needed a memory foam
mattress to provide the perfect amount
of support to keep him sleeping through
the night just go to helixlink.com
inside Marvel take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free he Helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com inside
Marvel we also want to thank wondery for
sponsoring this episode go deeper into
the canals of numenor in the minds of
Kaza doom and more with the official
Lord of the Rings the rings of power
podcast host Felicia Day and several
special guests provide an inside look at
the groundbreaking series and what it
took to bring Middle Earth to life each
episode of the official podcast features
exclusive interviews with the series
showrunners JD Payne and Patrick McKay
including the very first full breakdown
of the incredible season finale Felicia
goes behind the scenes with the cast and
crew to bring you jaw-dropping stories
and Easter eggs that you won't want to
miss watch the rings of power on Prime
video and listen to all eight episodes
of the official Lord of the Rings the
rings of power podcast for free on
Amazon music download the Amazon music
app now alright movie it on to Wonder
Man Simon Williams confirmed to be
played by Yaya Abdul Mateen the second
uh from such Fame as uh the DC Cinematic
Universe is uh you know a Black Manta
and he was in Watchmen on HBO uh he's so
so good
um let's talk about Simon Williams and
because this guy has a lot of
connections with this era of a red
Vision turning into white Vision when uh
like Vision dies right don't they use
Simon Williams's brain waves to
reanimate vision and that's kind of the
personality of vision is Simon
Williamson way obviously the MCU is
going to go in a different way Wonder
man's gonna be a different entity than
white what do you mean I want to see
Paul Bentley act like a black man
twice no it didn't no please
don't do that about that name
oh my God
but how do we think he's gonna connect
uh so Simon Williams is an actor like
he's a stunt actor specifically in
Hollywood it seems like it's gonna be I
mean my pitch for this in the past is
it's gonna be like Barry in the MCU
we're gonna see Simon Williams going in
on uh like auditions and things like
that he's gonna team up with uh Ralph
boner like I want these two to be
roommates oh honestly yeah yeah
I don't know a piece of me is like what
if they do change them up a little bit I
know that in the and I I I'm sorry I
keep going back to the comics for this
but I like the idea that in the comics
white vision went back to a scientist
and got brain waves from like their son
what if in this world it's like uh we do
make Wonder Man kind of a scientist or
some sort of just smarter character
and uh what are you talking about
very very intelligent people [ __ ] on
stuff man don't you put your words in my
mouth I've done that the vaccine to
covet so I don't want to hear anything
all right hey hey I'm not you guys are
putting your words
but I like the idea of him appearing in
that sort of manner
um or maybe just being affected to the
point where it's like I felt something
was going on here but I do like I think
which is I know we got mad about Ralph
boner but that seems like a more tee up
for this character than my idea uh Ralph
boner and him run into each other at
auditions I would love that I would
honestly really love it I want the
government to uh to like recruit Simon
Williams maybe he's like just an
All-Star stunt guy and he's just like
super physical he's got a real popular
personality in the industry and maybe
he's even like a famous actor in
Hollywood and so they're using him to
like do the you know the voice you know
how they'll get actors to do like like
um voice navigation for different apps
like maybe there's some kind of company
or a government service who wants to use
Simon Williams personality to recreate
some kind of new synthesis or something
like that and that's how he comes into
conflict with like Paul Bettany like the
these two are different versions of
vision uh and maybe like maybe there's
like a black mirror or untethered thing
where he dies in a stunt accident and
they use his Consciousness and they
implant it and then he's like I'm a
synthetic now what the [ __ ] freaking
hell and then
I would love if they um if like if Simon
Williams was still an actor but they
used like the fact that he had powers to
like play Vision in like movies like The
the movies that Hollywood and the MCU
was making of the Avengers like hey why
don't you just be Vision because you can
fly you would save us a ton on CG to
like just be Vision we haven't run into
that right we haven't run into like
cousin She-Hulk they really captured a
lot of like superheroes do other things
than be superheroes
um so that could happen in Vision Quest
of him being introduced as an actor of
vision and just being hired to do double
the work and being like you're also the
stunt man because you can do it I guess
my question is like what connection does
Wonder Man have to Magic do we know any
all I know about Wonder Man is that he's
very strong he's in love with the
Scarlet Witch which clearly probably
won't go in on this story in the MCU
well like Simon doesn't Simon Williams
have a connection to Grim Reaper like
his brother is the Grim Reaper Am I
Wrong oh yeah he is related to someone
someone missed it right that is true
but then they'd have to bring in two
characters yeah I don't think Wonder Man
is gonna get super mystical or anything
and I I honestly think that the
connection between Wonder Man and uh
Vision was one of those like weird like
comic book like we're just gonna write
this like just we just want to bring
Vision back to like you know let's use
his brain waves I don't think that
they're gonna really connect the two
characters at all other than like you
know maybe a wink and a nod reference
like oh
um like you know me and vision are
connected it's like yeah I don't think
it's gonna be anything substantial in
the MCU though I would love to see it um
you know what which I don't know if they
would do this I don't know if they would
do this I don't know what they would do
this but we do know that he is also in
the Candyman married to Tiana Paris and
what if he's shown up and he's there and
he has to fight Monica and then they
fall in love uh just just banking on
something I also and maybe it is they
hire him to fight like someone in Agatha
House of Harkness because they don't
have anyone and wonder man is definitely
a tee up for like any government of
being like hey I'm not going to call
upon this guy that did a public
execution and the freaking Falcon in the
Winter Soldier what's his name Johnny
mayonnaise so we're gonna call upon
another dude and it's Wonder Man maybe
that could be it or maybe he is gonna
fall in love with Tiana Paris I'm just
saying they've already done it once
might as well do it again
um what's it called I think Wonder Man
and um Captain Marvel dated at one point
in the Marvel comics from now he was
dating everybody so like he's true they
never Wonder man's kind of a hoe but
like I would love to see wonder man just
like I don't know like him him and Carol
like maybe have a pass together maybe
like it like some I don't know because
like they're both super powered people
like they're he's one of the strongest
people in in in Marvel
um so like I don't know like I'm just
wondering how they're going to portray
this character in his own show um
because he was sort of like an [ __ ]
in his own way so like I'm really
interested to see
um how they do that but anyway well
either way amazing casting I mean God
Sarah Haley Finn she she is she is she's
the Wonder literally the queen of
casting she does no wrong at any point
in her career she has done no wrong I'm
trying to think some of the is has any I
mean we're also married to the current
casting of the MCU has there been any
incidents where we're like really that
could have done better than that person
in that role I don't think we're none of
us are willing you really want to know
mine you want to know mine and it's just
it's only out of like bitterness it is
not out of anything else
Charlize Theron is clear
I genuinely was like
fits the thing is I think it's fine but
there are so many blonde women in
Hollywood you could have chose from that
I haven't seen or I've seen very little
of and so that's why I was like I've
seen Charlize Theron and everything
since I've been born I mean yeah she
fits well with Doctor Strange I'm sure
they put them next to each other and was
like can we see them be these two
married but I'm like I was like Charlie
get the hell out of here get out I was
like I'm so tired of seeing you
everywhere girl oh but it was fine it's
fine I haven't seen her as Cleo yet so I
can't get too irritated and she's a good
actress so it's not like I'm gonna hate
the acting yeah no like usually like I'm
happy with like all the choices um that
Sarah has made but like honestly I think
I would recast
um Jane Foster like I love Natalie
Portman she's a fantastic actress
I I feel like Jane Foster considering
like you know she does inherit the role
of Thor I think that
maybe somebody different might have uh I
don't know like I just I just feel like
I'm walking out of this conversation
could have like fit somewhere else in
the MCU
um maybe as a different hero but like I
just think that the whole Jane Foster
character I don't know maybe take this
out I love that I don't mean to be mean
oh let's let's get tough on it
um okay here's I'll throw a really tough
one in here and it's hard because uh I
really love this actor we might have had
a better Doctor Strange out there than
Benedict Cumberbatch Benedict matches no
Thanksgiving he is fantastic in this
role and he all makes sense in our heads
but I'm just saying there are other like
Hollywood kind of got really excited by
Benedict Cumberbatch and like I don't
know if he brought anything new to it to
be honest I agree I agree I think we're
just now like Doctor Strange is Benedict
and Benedict is Doctor Strange but I
also think there are like a handful of
men that could have taken that role as
well and I
Doctor Strange if you ask me that's the
thing that's the thing though is like
Kiana or Doctor Strange plays different
than like Robert Downey Jr as Iron Man
because we know Iron Man is like so
egotistical and all this stuff so it's
like Robert Downey Jr plays that very
well doctor strange doesn't really have
too much emotion to be like tossing out
so I'm like
how are you gonna change this roll up I
had a whole conversation with some
friend we're gonna wrap up real quick um
but I think like the way Benedict has
been doing Doctor Strange is basically
the way Robert Downey Jr has been doing
Iron Man he's just kind of a smart ass
he's gonna be the smartest one in the
room I think he's doing the he's doing
an impression of of Robert Downey
engineer's Tony Stark whereas Doctor
Strange in the comics he is this guy who
has his connection with the mystical
world and he's like I don't I haven't
really seen true awe from Stephen
Strange in the MCU awe it is a profound
emotion where you are able to experience
something that shatters your Paradigm of
what you previously thought to be true
and you were mourning the death of that
old Paradigm so there's like tears
rolling down your Che cheeks your uh
your mind is being blown and maybe it's
just the way these moves are made it's
hard for anyone to look at a green
screen set and be like I understand what
I'm looking at right now but I think
Keanu Reeves that guy knows ah look at
him in the Matrix movies so much of that
story is just in his eyes and his
expression says he's just like what that
show am I looking at right now and we
connect with him and I think we need
that with with Dr Strange a little bit I
don't know if Benedict has given it to
us he has sometimes I'm being hard on
him there's I can probably point to
specific moments where I was like all
right Benedict [ __ ] nailed that
moment you know but it's hard it's a
hard character so attracted to Benedict
Cumberbatch that I look past everything
me too I think he's won us over just
with his little charms it's just other
actors work really really hard to win us
over and he doesn't have to work as hard
because he's stuck also I'm waiting I
don't know if she wants to be I'm
waiting for them to cast Kira Knightley
in the MCU because they are best friends
in real life and I think on screen they
would also make that play really well
because they've been in like two movies
together so cascara nightly hurry up oh
you know we overlooked Rachel McAdams
probably miscast as Christine Palmer
right oh we will talk about this offline
yeah
then against Rachel got him so I think
she's great
um but I don't know if that's anyway
anyway this is a very mean segment of
like but this is why none of us
like we love all these all these actors
they all did the best with what they
were giving you know no no one has
really freaking biffed it I think we can
say we can agree I don't know yeah 100
your mileage may vary I suppose but
we'll leave it there for this episode of
inside Marvel you can follow me any of
us follow Jessica at Lulu underscore
Clemens follow Mt at masterton subscribe
to inside Marvel wherever you get your
podcast hey once we all see black
panther we're kind of forever
um in a couple weeks we're gonna do a
whole like uh discussion on that and
then we're gonna rank all the phase four
movies but we have to all see it first
so that episode is coming up way Grace
for it it's gonna be fun it's gonna get
it's gonna get nasty uh space four mix
back but hey hey thank you all so much
for watching and uh we will see you next
week bye bye everybody bye guys
foreign